I know with this next bit we are walking
straight into a crap storm umbrellas are
advised yes so please just hear me out
because we're talking about Sports
Illustrated and fat chicks we're about
to sail into a trip typhoon Randy so
we've been our haul in the jib before it
gets covered with
okay so first before you get all mad
about fat shaming there'll be plenty of
that down the line that's not the main
point here Sports Illustrated had three
covers Ronda Rousey some moderately cute
blonde I don't know her name and then
then your big girl Ashley Graham is that
it I think so yeah Ashley Graham okay
now before we get into all this is not
about hating fat people okay
this is a truth here okay this is not
about big beauty Sports Illustrated is
simply using this as a new marketing
gimmick to make fat girls feel good
about themselves he's about to enter the
tornado to Oz this is nothing to do with
reflecting normal bodies okay look at
Ashley Graham any of you out there look
like that right okay she's a size 16 she
says she's 5 9 size 16 what you know
she's probably pushing it she's probably
more like 5 7 5 8 size 18 which okay
first is not normal that is overweight
that is significantly she's not like
test holiday you shouldn't have an
orbits but she's relatively large and by
the way we include average to give you
an example I have a great family doctor
before we get into this okay average is
a number that's just thrown about oh so
average is size 14 F that includes the
entire population including the morbidly
obese people who are unhealthy and have
diabetes and health conditions for
example when I was going through some
tests with my doctor I said well what's
the normal range we're testing my
thyroid it turns out I've talked about
this I've had an issue with it because
well depends here's the range that was
acceptable by doctors for a long time
but that also includes people in the
general population with hypothyroidism
and diabetes because you remove those
people and include only the healthy
population that range diminishes greatly
so let's be clear about that what we're
talking about average sometimes it's a
lot better to watch it didn't regrow
than to try to shake the [ __ ] fruit out
of it real quick want to tell you bout a
sponsorship this week audible.com go to
audible.com slash Crowder and you can
try it for free you can actually listen
to any audiobook which is actually great
for us and we're doing show prep and
we're reading news I don't have time to
read a book but we can actually listen
to a book while we're reading news it's
been great for us particularly if you're
interested in the top
and you really want to learn and you
have your headphones on I recommend a
few books I actually recommend Big Love
sex and relationship guide for people of
size and those who love them and by that
I mean I actually recommend Brad doors
recent short story the afternoon
solution is or I hope yeah that's the
one the other one let me pick it if you
want but the Brad door book I highly
recommend he's a friend of the show it's
a short audio book it's only about an
hour and it's a great story brett doors
a good guy audible.com slash Crowder
please support the show go there and try
it for free what do you have to lose
well I think what you have to lose if
you don't go there
so my cue points because you will get
stupider for not reading or listening to
people read now this woman is not
showcasing her body for what it is this
is my issue with it's just another
marketing gimmick to sell makeup beauty
products fitness products as we'll get
to with this gram on her Instagram
account
she is the message here is be proud of
your big is beautiful so long as you are
as long as you have a skinny face
airbrushed Photoshop perfect teeth skin
and hair then you can be beautiful well
if we're going to talk about
representing all body cams why are you
all of a sudden is a test holiday and
this girl and not hey you know here's
actually a healthy young blonde girl
with ruddy skin and small boobs what
about what about the girl with with
psoriasis who's perfectly healthy what
about the girl with acne and the hook
nose wait what are your thoughts on the
the blue vein in the old boob the blue
vein in the boob well it's photoshopped
out
oh it's photoshoots were sense now cuz I
would assume the woman of her size would
have it so the message here is it's okay
to be plus-sized diabetic size even so
long as everything else is perfect by
the way buy this stuff in a rush
barometer is Bo measures the pressure in
the air
sans are the whispering oh [ __ ] okay and
I've said this before I know I'll get
guff I think Adele is I think Adele is
sexy right and I know people say well
without makeup okay
so why am I being so harsh here listen
it's because these plus-sized models are
thrusting their body in front of men and
demanding that you see it as beautiful
and if you don't you are to be
reprimanded that's the problem if a
plus-sized woman says hey I'm a great
singer right and I go oh okay I listen
to them saying the plus the fatness has
nothing to do with it yeah you know
you're a great singer if a plus-sized
woman an extra plus plus-sized woman
comes to me and says I'm beautiful and I
have a great body okay I'm going to look
at your body and say no disagree oh mama
D for rebuttal I object your honor
winter coming the real problem is these
plus-size models are charlatans okay can
you bring up case in point this this
gram girl her her Instagram of her doing
this exercise oh goodness
so what is the point here they go health
comes in all shapes and sizes
look I'm exercising really hard and I'm
still this size no no you're not as a
matter of fact that's this exercise we
should have it up on screen um
her trainer should be given an award for
conmen a comment of the year because
this movement is a marvel what she is
doing here I'm doing a complex at the
bunch of moments to burn calories no
there's a reason you're big probably
because this is how you train
she's taking a single leg lunge okay a
single leg lunge now everyone watching
pause this video right now just go do a
lunge put your foot up on a chair do a
single leg lunge okay it's really easy
barring someone who has a disability
anyone can do it now it's so easy that
the only real time people do it in the
gym is when they add weight to them
typically a barbell dumbbells ideally
bar because you need a lot of weight to
really make that difficult again pause
this go do a lunge it's really easy
right so what this woman is doing is
taking a movement a gravity based
movement the lunge requires gravity as
resistance and combining it with a cable
crossover and anti-gravity
movement a movement that has weight
coming from a pulley system in the
ceiling so she has taken a gravity
movement and an anti gravity movement to
fool herself as she does all kinds of
physical motion well and we'll never
ever encountering any resistance
whatsoever what she is doing here is
more akin to the the weightless space
the weightless machine at Space Camp did
you ever go to Space Camp no no thanks
for bringing that up though Stephen
here's the little fun fact about Space
Camp comes with a lot of ass kickings so
look at those anyway so I would have
rather done it in a weightless space and
put you in this machine that's like you
know you're basically move and the
leverage causes that momentum to go
somewhere else so you know if I push
here it actually resists against it
that's the whole thing she's movement is
more akin to the antigravity machine at
Space Camp than it is to any kind of
actual exercise you idiots have loaded
up a hair-trigger double-barreled spit
machine gun and the barrels pointed
straight at your own heads it sounds
like so it's a con job that Polly is
literally pulling her out of the lunch
so when you just did your single weight
lunge there even without any and how
easy it was hers is easier then that
it's like when you were a kid in high
school and you went to the pulldown
machine you put on all this weight and
had your friend told you Danny okay let
me go and you let them slingshot you up
she's doing that now or like when your
parents think Alecto in the doorway with
one of those as a toddler seats yes yeah
can they rescue a dog the kids are
getting along and it malls your face and
they have to surgically reattach it
you're like you're balancing and having
a great time so does it matter
Oh Roscoe we shouldn't have rescued you
I didn't know you were a paid dog so the
point is she is doing less than you will
do right now when you pause this video
she is doing less than that and claiming
that she's exercising really hard but
this is just how big she is and she's
going to sell the celebrity was a curvy
Fit Club she's going to start selling
DVDs and you'll have women out there who
are overweight who will do this useless
training never lose weight and say I'm
fit and I'm healthy because I move a lot
no you're not you're lying to yourself
my problem here is listen if you want to
be big if you that's
fine but just admit it don't find ways
to trick people so you can sell things
the abyss the [ __ ] abyss just as an
example guarantee of Graham stops this
BS separates the two motions okay
lunge with a barbell now the lunge has
not only bodyweight resistance because I
mean you may even just need bodyweight
but let's say add a barbell you have
lunge bodyweight resistance separate it
stop that
then go do cable crossover or if your
trainer actually knows anything about
anything do some pull-ups for you it'll
take a while to get to one pull-up okay
do some pull downs the point is do an
actual complex of cup of compound
movements that would involve major
muscle groups and then do basic cardio
or conditioning it's not reinventing the
guarantee you guarantee you as a matter
of fact I would put up a hundred
thousand dollars right now to any
overweight people out there guarantee
you if you do that okay and you can
monitor it you will lose weight
guarantee you gram would lose weight but
she can't do that why because then she's
out of a job no one wants a moderately a
pretty attractive kind of slightly
overweight model they want the really
big plus-size model who's famous for
being plus-size but happens to have the
proportions of a skinny face no blue
vein in their boob perfect teeth perfect
skin so they can sell makeup and curve
fit clubz does the DVD agonizes DVD come
with the 20 pounds of premium makeup and
the professional Photoshop artist or is
that separate is that one things like if
you order now in the next five minutes
you have to price yes it's comes
complimentary with the Gravitron
weightless machine
well that was brilliant marketing right
there that was that's good she would
have she would have more resistance
squatting in a pool this is the point
this is the slippery slope right most
guys would prefer a different model
she's not a bad-looking woman that's not
the point here Sports Illustrated will
brag about how they have 73 million
subscribers which by the way is BS for
this issue they met by up each other's
magazine subscriptions it's a
little-known secret anyone who's worked
in the publishing industry knows that
they constantly inflate their numbers
anyway they will say 73 million
subscribers right now if you were to act
but they what they won't tell you is how
many of these 73 million men who buy
this copy of say okay which one is your
favorite cover we'll choose miss size 16
they'll never release those numbers
my problem here is not with big women my
problem is not with skinny women my
problem is not with attractive or
unattractive woman my problem is with
women who throw market responses to the
wind the free market to the wind thrust
themselves in the spotlight and demand
that you call them beautiful and say
that it's hateful to say otherwise
so yeah the slippery slope you have
social justice warriors now saying well
this isn't enough why don't we have
everyone the woman at soccer practice
here's the deal models don't need to
represent an accurate intersection of
the populace they just I don't expect to
be on the cover of anything of course
not and we don't expect models to give
us a next care for cancer we want you to
look good half naked that's your job
that's your job now if you come in
half-naked in a lot of people said yeah
but the goes back on you've done your
job poorly you're you should you should
be fired you're bad at your job it's
gone one step too far we're in the Irish
picking here Julian Ricky isn't Lucius
and these fad models are liars they're
just as they claim that they want to
they want to help women with their body
image they lie just as bad as any other
model they lie about their skin they
photoshopped their cellulite they
photoshopped their hair they change
their pigment to appear generically
ethnic so they can claim diversity but
not intimidate white people and they do
this to sell you more crap it's a
marketing angle and what bothers me is
that fat chicks and their white night
social justice where your boyfriend's
have bought it and they're trying to
appease them but here's the problem if
you call them out on their by the way a
woman now is the same size of the
average men from the 1960s
you can't account for that by drinking
their Ovaltine okay that's a significant
change diabetes this is the first
generation who's not expected to live as
long as their parents they're not
expected to live as long as a generation
before them this is the first generation
that's happened it's because of chronic
diseases they're largely preventable
heart disease diabetes all the kind of
things listen Kevin all shapes and sizes
there are outliers as a general rule no
it's a general rule that's not true as a
general rule health comes in a pretty
defined
range of of shapes and sizes so it's all
it's the lying that bothers me that's
the line to sell curvy Fitness tapes and
fake asses on People magazine and
telling everyone that they're healthy
when they're really not and if you call
them out on their lies well you've just
opened Pandora's box because by golly
that's hate speech you just open
Pandora's getfox right hey glad to see
you subscribe by clicking my face or the
button above that says subscribe I know
you don't have to you can close the
window but joke's on you there's a pipe
bomb in your basement and I have the
detonator I highly recommend you
subscribe and even then you're still
rolling the dice it depends on my mood
is that day